Computers used to be as big as a room.
But now they fit in your pocket,
on your wrist
and can even be implanted
inside of your body.
How cool is that?
And this has been enabled
by the miniaturization of transistors,
which are the tiny switches
in the circuits
at the heart of our computers.
And it's been achieved
through decades of development
and breakthroughs
in science and engineering
and of billions of dollars of investment.
But it's given us
vast amounts of computing,
huge amounts of memory
and the digital revolution
that we all experience and enjoy today.
But the bad news is,
we're about to hit a digital roadblock,
as the rate of miniaturization
of transistors is slowing down.
And this is happening
at exactly the same time
as our innovation in software
is continuing relentlessly
with artificial intelligence and big data.
And our devices regularly perform
facial recognition or augment our reality
or even drive cars down
our treacherous, chaotic roads.
It's amazing.
But if we don't keep up
with the appetite of our software,
we could reach a point
in the development of our technology
where the things that we could do
with software could, in fact, be limited
by our hardware.
We've all experienced the frustration
of an old smartphone or tablet
grinding slowly to a halt over time
under the ever-increasing weight
of software updates and new features.
And it worked just fine
when we bought it not so long ago.
But the hungry software engineers
have eaten up all the hardware capacity
over time.
The semiconductor industry
is very well aware of this
and is working on
all sorts of creative solutions,
such as going beyond transistors
to quantum computing
or even working with transistors
in alternative architectures
such as neural networks
to make more robust
and efficient circuits.
But these approaches
will take quite some time,
and we're really looking for a much more
immediate solution to this problem.
The reason why the rate of miniaturization
of transistors is slowing down
is due to the ever-increasing complexity
of the manufacturing process.
The transistor used to be
a big, bulky device,
until the invent of the integrated circuit
based on pure crystalline silicon wafers.
And after 50 years
of continuous development,
we can now achieve
transistor features dimensions
down to 10 nanometers.
You can fit more than
a billion transistors
in a single square millimeter of silicon.
And to put this into perspective:
a human hair is 100 microns across.
A red blood cell,
which is essentially invisible,
is eight microns across,
and you can place 12 across
the width of a human hair.
But a transistor, in comparison,
is much smaller,
at a tiny fraction of a micron across.
You could place more than 260 transistors
across a single red blood cell
or more than 3,000 across
the width of a human hair.
It really is incredible nanotechnology
in your pocket right now.
And besides the obvious benefit
of being able to place more,
smaller transistors on a chip,
smaller transistors are faster switches,
and smaller transistors are also
more efficient switches.
So this combination has given us
lower cost, higher performance
and higher efficiency electronics
that we all enjoy today.
To manufacture these integrated circuits,
the transistors are built up
layer by layer,
on a pure crystalline silicon wafer.
And in an oversimplified sense,
every tiny feature
of the circuit is projected
onto the surface of the silicon wafer
and recorded in a light-sensitive material
and then etched through
the light-sensitive material
to leave the pattern
in the underlying layers.
And this process has been
dramatically improved over the years
to give the electronics
performance we have today.
But as the transistor features
get smaller and smaller,
we're really approaching
the physical limitations
of this manufacturing technique.
The latest systems
for doing this patterning
have become so complex
that they reportedly cost
more than 100 million dollars each.
And semiconductor factories
contain dozens of these machines.
So people are seriously questioning:
Is this approach long-term viable?
But we believe we can do
this chip manufacturing
in a totally different
and much more cost-effective way
using molecular engineering
and mimicking nature
down at the nanoscale dimensions
of our transistors.
As I said, the conventional manufacturing
takes every tiny feature of the circuit
and projects it onto the silicon.
But if you look at the structure
of an integrated circuit,
the transistor arrays,
many of the features are repeated
millions of times.
It's a highly periodic structure.
So we want to take advantage
of this periodicity
in our alternative
manufacturing technique.
We want to use self-assembling materials
to naturally form the periodic structures
that we need for our transistors.
We do this with the materials,
then the materials do the hard work
of the fine patterning,
rather than pushing the projection
technology to its limits and beyond.
Self-assembly is seen in nature
in many different places,
from lipid membranes to cell structures,
so we do know it can be a robust solution.
If it's good enough for nature,
it should be good enough for us.
So we want to take this naturally
occurring, robust self-assembly
and use it for the manufacturing
of our semiconductor technology.
One type of self-assemble material --
it's called a block co-polymer --
consists of two polymer chains
just a few tens of nanometers in length.
But these chains hate each other.
They repel each other,
very much like oil and water
or my teenage son and daughter.
(Laughter)
But we cruelly bond them together,
creating an inbuilt
frustration in the system,
as they try to separate from each other.
And in the bulk material,
there are billions of these,
and the similar components
try to stick together,
and the opposing components
try to separate from each other
at the same time.
And this has a built-in frustration,
a tension in the system.
So it moves around, it squirms
until a shape is formed.
And the natural self-assembled shape
that is formed is nanoscale,
it's regular, it's periodic,
and it's long range,
which is exactly what we need
for our transistor arrays.
So we can use molecular engineering
to design different shapes
of different sizes
and of different periodicities.
So for example, if we take
a symmetrical molecule,
where the two polymer chains
are similar length,
the natural self-assembled
structure that is formed
is a long, meandering line,
very much like a fingerprint.
And the width of the fingerprint lines
and the distance between them
is determined by the lengths
of our polymer chains
but also the level of built-in
frustration in the system.
And we can even create
more elaborate structures
if we use unsymmetrical molecules,
where one polymer chain
is significantly shorter than the other.
And the self-assembled structure
that forms in this case
is with the shorter chains
forming a tight ball in the middle,
and it's surrounded by the longer,
opposing polymer chains,
forming a natural cylinder.
And the size of this cylinder
and the distance between
the cylinders, the periodicity,
is again determined by how long
we make the polymer chains
and the level of built-in frustration.
So in other words, we're using
molecular engineering
to self-assemble nanoscale structures
that can be lines or cylinders
the size and periodicity of our design.
We're using chemistry,
chemical engineering,
to manufacture the nanoscale features
that we need for our transistors.
But the ability
to self-assemble these structures
only takes us half of the way,
because we still need
to position these structures
where we want the transistors
in the integrated circuit.
But we can do this relatively easily
using wide guide structures that pin down
the self-assembled structures,
anchoring them in place
and forcing the rest
of the self-assembled structures
to lie parallel,
aligned with our guide structure.
For example, if we want to make
a fine, 40-nanometer line,
which is very difficult to manufacture
with conventional projection technology,
we can manufacture
a 120-nanometer guide structure
with normal projection technology,
and this structure will align three
of the 40-nanometer lines in between.
So the materials are doing
the most difficult fine patterning.
And we call this whole approach
"directed self-assembly."
The challenge with directed self-assembly
is that the whole system
needs to align almost perfectly,
because any tiny defect in the structure
could cause a transistor failure.
And because there are billions
of transistors in our circuit,
we need an almost
molecularly perfect system.
But we're going to extraordinary measures
to achieve this,
from the cleanliness of our chemistry
to the careful processing
of these materials
in the semiconductor factory
to remove even the smallest
nanoscopic defects.
So directed self-assembly
is an exciting new disruptive technology,
but it is still in the development stage.
But we're growing in confidence
that we could, in fact, introduce it
to the semiconductor industry
as a revolutionary new
manufacturing process
in just the next few years.
And if we can do this,
if we're successful,
we'll be able to continue
with the cost-effective
miniaturization of transistors,
continue with the spectacular
expansion of computing
and the digital revolution.
And what's more, this could even
be the dawn of a new era
of molecular manufacturing.
How cool is that?
Thank you.
(Applause)